there's not a face for every culture
every ethnicity every race so when you
tell me that I'm too dark to be
Dominican show me what its minikin looks
like and then try to tell me that I'm
not Dominican enough because you're
wrong I'm Dominican I'm black I'm gonna
fluff it up and you can't tell me any
difference
[Music]
in Africa thena is simply a person who
just identifies with their blackness
that's it I'm a black girl and my family
is from Dominican Republic but people
say I'm too dark to be Dominican people
say I can't be latina growing up there
was no one who looked like me I remember
just being called charcoal I remember
being called too dirty at one point I
stopped saying all the Semitic my goal
is simply to be able to help the youth
feel comfortable in their skin and own
it oh yeah girl okay
hello Oh Tommy Tommy Rondo most people
know me as Monica style Muse over on
YouTube Instagram you name it I've been
able to be extremely successful as an
afro latina in the beauty space this is
one of my favorite eyebrow pencils
because the precision just makes your
brows you know I live for a brow lift
I'm not the best makeup artist and never
did I ever say I was but I feel like if
I can at least just inspire other people
to just live in their own truth
regardless of what other people think it
took me maybe three years to really find
myself
and to be my own muse on my channel you
can print this all over your face to
really bring the moisture back into your
face so you look refreshed one day I
just decided you know what I'm gonna be
myself and bad and said that him
everyone in McClendon at first when I
started speaking Spanish on my channel
they were like can you stop this can you
just make a separate Channel and I said
you know what no this is who I am and it
was the best decision I've ever made for
myself being a Latina means knowing that
you have a culture and a background and
a story that can't also
my audience is this sassy person who is
just so ready to take on whatever the
world throws at them they're gonna
figure it out one way or another and
that's what I've done even like thinking
back to little Monica baby Monica was so
timid she was so scared of the world I'm
an adult now you can't really faze me
cause people do they more less that
which means if my shine bothers you
that's not my problem
[Music]